for months now
I've been trying and failing to figure out a way to wear my gold because like
I'm Egyptian I should be a gold girly
but like I
I wear silver
I'm a silver girl through and through
but like as an Egyptian
for baptisms for like holidays whatever
like we get gold
so I have gold that I've gotten from my family
they've literally never worn because I just didn't know how to
so this is my first actual attempt and I'm gonna wear this out
i'mma be really brave
but it's still
there's still something missing
I'm trying to layer it because the thing is my nose ring is silver and my
these two are silver
and this is silver
can you see this is silver
these are silver
but I got these gold earrings for Christmas and I found these um
this I got this summer in Egypt
it had a bigger cross on it
every time I get golden
Egypt is usually a cross or some sort
so I have a lot
but I'm trying to
I'm just trying
okay this is basically what I came up with
this is my baby ring from
you know when I was a kid
um this is a cross
and these are silver
so I don't I still don't know what to do though
cause it's still
something is missing and I don't know what
this is Sterling silver that's like
plated with gold
this is just not gold
but whatever and I put these two gold bracelets on my stack
I just there's something missing and I don't know what else to do
but I really I wanna pull it off and I just don't know what to do
so if you have any suggestions
please let me know
I wanna be a gold girl so bad